there is now overwhelming evidence that
apple's new
fully redesigned 14 and 16 inch macbook
pros
will be announced at apple's wwdc event
on june 7. now i know you might think
i'm crazy
but hear me out there are so many puzzle
pieces
that have finally come together which
i'm gonna show you
in this video so just like before when i
called the imac release
a week before the april event i'm gonna
do it again
and just call it apple's new redesigned
macbook pros
will be announced at their wwdc event
and if i'm wrong i will be shaving my
goatee
which thankfully was spared last time so
if you want a chance to see
that subscribe right now to help us
reach our goal of a million subscribers
by the end of this year but with that
said let's quickly go through the
history of
leaks and rumors for these redesigned
machines before i get into the
overwhelming evidence
for the new macbook pros coming at wwdc
the 14 inch macbook pro has been rumored
for literally over a year now
ever since michiko mentioned it back in
march of 2020
as one of apple's next mini led products
and that's very important because apple
has already revealed
the mini led ipad pro with insanely
impressive display performance and
analysts are expecting that same tech
to come to the redesigned 14 and 16-inch
macbook pros as well
with trend force claiming that they're
launching in the second half of 2021
which begins in july and after those
initial reports that we got last year
we continued to get reports after report
of these new macbook pros coming
with mini led displays as soon as july
2021
which many analysts agreed on and then
last month nikkei
asia reported that the mass production
of the new redesigned macbook pro models
will not happen until the second half of
2021
which really makes it seem like they're
not coming until at least
fall but due to recent revelations that
were just
revealed i think that they're coming
sooner than we thought
literally just this morning we got a
groundbreaking report from the same
nikkei asia publication claiming that
the next generation
mack chip has already entered mass
production
this month destined for the redesigned
macbook pros
now i know that the article says the m2
chip
which is causing a bunch of confusion in
the comment section
because all of us are expecting the m1x
chip
not the next generation m2 but if you
look closely at what the article says
they mentioned that it's tentatively
known as the m2
which basically means that the name is
subject to further confirmation
from apple and if you think about it
last year everybody thought that the
first apple silicon chip
was gonna be named the a14x until apple
finally revealed the new m1 chip
for the mac so based on that i still
personally believe
that we're going to be getting the m1x
chip in those redesigned macbook pros
with most likely 12 cores for the cpu
and 16 cores for the gpu
but enough about that let's get back to
the main point of that article
the upcoming m1x chip has already
entered
mass production like right now so
here is the main question that we need
to think about if apple's pumping these
chips out right now
why would they have them sitting around
on shelves for months
until some apple event in the fall
because first of all
we know that these macbook pros are
going to be a huge deal
and they definitely deserve some screen
time at an official apple event
so if they don't show them off at wwdc
the next event would most likely have to
be either in october
or november since september is never
focused on mac products
it's just iphones apple watches and
stuff like that
so why would apple start mass production
of the m1x right now
and have them sitting and waiting around
until october
or november it just doesn't make sense
and that's why i'm calling an
announcement at wwdc
but wait i've got a whole lot more
evidence that points to this
actually happening last year in
september digitimes reported that mass
production for the a14x chip
which ended up being called the m1 would
begin
in the fourth quarter of 2020 which
began
in october and as we know apple
announced those maps on
november 10th so that's a maximum of
five weeks
between starting mass production of the
chip itself
and announcing the actual max so if this
report from nikkei asia is true
and the higher end macbook pro apple
silicon chips have already started
production
right now that gives us around six weeks
between the start of chip production
and apple's wwdc event somewhat matching
up to the m1 chip timeline that we had
last year
and there is one more puzzle piece that
now adds up
and makes total sense apple revealed
their 24-inch redesigned imac
and their new m1 ipad pro at their april
20th
event but they're not even allowing
orders to be made
until the 30th and they said that
shipments won't even happen
until the second half of may and john
prosser recently got info from sources
saying that he believes that the new
ipad pro could launch on may 21st
which is actually over a month after the
april event
so hear me out what if apple announces
the new m1x macbook pros
at wwdc and then does the same exact
thing
pushing the actual launch date an entire
month out
into july this would match up perfectly
to the many reports that claim that the
redesigned macbook pros
are coming in the second half of 2021
which technically starts in
july and if you think about it the first
retina macbook pro was revealed at
apple's wwdc event in 2012
and they also have a history of
releasing macbook pros in july
like when they updated them on july 29th
2014
and then in july of 2018 when they added
six core processors and then once again
in 2019
updating them for the back to school
season so it definitely wouldn't be
surprising to see these redesigned
macbook pros get announced
at wwdc since that would allow apple
to focus on the larger imac release in
the fourth quarter of this year
and if you're still having a hard time
believing in all of this
here's how i can imagine the event going
down tim cook
walks out onto the stage and talks about
the massive success
of their apple silicon transition which
was first announced at last year's wwdc
and then he's gonna talk about the great
success of the m1 chip
and how well it's been selling compared
to their intel based models
and then finally they'll reveal the next
step
in the transition which is the new m1x
chip
going into the redesigned macbook pros
and maybe even the mac mini
so yeah if you look at it that way you
can totally see it happening
and with all that said the final piece
of evidence
is that we've been seeing more and more
leaks and rumors about these new macbook
pros
over the last couple of months which
usually happens
not too long before an official
announcement for example
both ming chico and mark german claimed
that the redesigned macbook pros
would have a new flat edge design with
more ports like an sd card slot
hdmi and even a new mac safe charging
port
and then just a few days ago a hacking
group actually stole the schematics
for these redesigned macbook pros which
clearly show an
hdmi port an sd card slot more flat
sides
and the removal of the touch bar which
confirms
the previous reports and on top of that
we're also expecting the new mini led
display
as well as of course the m1x chip which
was allegedly leaked within
mac os beta code which also usually only
happens close to a release date so
based on all of those little puzzle
pieces finally coming together
i'm just gonna go ahead and call it and
say that the redesigned macbook pros
will be revealed at apple's wwdc event
and if you're curious about the specs
and the pricing
i'll quickly finish off this video with
my thoughts on that there's a small
chance that the 14 inch macbook pro
might actually come with the regular m1
ship
at the base 1800 price and then have an
upgrade option
for the m1x but i feel like paying 1800
for the same m1 chip as you get in a
macbook air is a bit of a rip
off but then again if you really think
about it the current
1800 intel based macbook pro already
comes with
16 gigs of ram and 512 gigs of storage
at the base price so if apple matches
those specs
for the new 14 inch base model you're
really only paying a hundred dollars
more
for the new redesign and the new display
compared to a similarly configured
current m1 macbook pro which isn't that
bad at all
so the m1 chip and the base 14 inch is
still a possibility
and then of course the 16 inch macbook
pro will get the m1x
at the base 2400 price but either way
i'm expecting new redesigned macbook
pros at wwdc
and if you totally disagree with my
speculation and reasoning
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you agree with me
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
check one of those two out right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you